so this work is part of a larger thread
of work centered around algorithmic
governance that is how do we audit and
measure problematic content like Mis
disinformation uh online extremism and
how do we do that on online platforms
and then specifically the search and
recommendation algorithms driving these
platforms so as as I Was preparing for
this talk I I thought of opening it up
in a slightly unconventional way with
this this particular quote um which I'm
going to read a little bit um which says
mankind barely noticed when the concept
of massively organized information
quietly emerged to become a means of
social control a weapon of war and a
road map for group destruction any
guesses as to which year of the world
this quote uh describes is it the world
is is it a current world 2020s uh 2000s
1900s
some people could guess just by the word
Mankind in in previous talk
um yeah that that's that's absolutely
accurate so this is actually Edwin
Black's description of the world of the
1930s 1940s uh during the World War II
and the invention of the punch card uh
which was at that time the new wave of
Automation and uh data collection and
and what is more surprising is that this
code is still true in today's 2st
Century world and we have seen many new
scholarships and I'm sure folks here
have uh read and are familiar with these
books many of these outline the harms of
Automation and data collection and more
recently this discussion has shifted uh
to the harms posed by generative Ai and
large language models so I'm going to
read this quote a little bit more of
what Edwin black had to say in his book
U which is a lot of parallels to a
present day world so he goes on to say
uh the unique igniting event was the
most fateful day of the last century
when Adolf Hitler came to power uh but
for the first time in history an anti-at
had automation on his side so that was
what was different and the automation
was in the form of IBM punch guards so
he goes on to say that IBM was self
griped by a special immoral corporate
Mantra if it can be done it should be
done so we should take a pause and and
kind of reread this phrase if it can be
done it should be done which is
parallels very e resemblance to the
motors and culture pra practiced in
modern day technology companies and I'm
sure uh being in the Silicon Valley uh
you all probably have U seen some of
this while interning at some of these
companies move fast and break things
done is better than perfect what would
you do if you weren't a afraid and I
argue that this sort of rush culture the
sort of culture of disruption and speed
often poses a great challenges in
governing these Technologies and
conducting thoughtful medicalis Audits
and in turn this is what makes
algorithmic governance a difficult
problem and I'll come back back to these
ideas later on towards the end of the
talk but let me first dive into the meat
of this presentation um a couple of
studies which we did uh in in this realm
of algorithmic governance so here I want
to focus on two types of algorithms uh
search and recommendations and two
specific FL platforms YouTube and Amazon
and our Focus was on was only one type
of problem misinformation
particularly now you might wonder like
why search and recommendation algorithms
right so now the word is moving towards
large language models why we should
focus on these old Technologies right
search and recommendations so users
generally have an unwavering trust in
search engines right so several
scholarly work some of these cited here
have actually shown that the these
ranking of search results have really
dramatic effect on users attitudes their
preferences their behaviors um in fact
uh bias search rankings are so powerful
they can even shift voting preferences
of undecided voters spite so much so as
uh 20% and users don't even show
awareness of that kind of manipulation
happening in their search results so
this should tell you how powerful search
algorithms is and then that is why we
should keep studying them despite the
other new shiny Technologies coming our
way uh for recommendation algorithms I
hope I don't have to make a case here
because you see those almost everywhere
starting from what recommendations uh
what movies you should watch what
products one should buy which campaign
you should donate to they are almost
everywhere and they also have these
reinforcing effect right so the more you
like uh watch certain content the more
you share the more you get those types
of
content now this might be harmless say
when uh you're going out this weekend
and trying to buy Christmas decorations
but the these things can get ugly quite
quickly when say um you are browsing for
vaccine information health information
or climate
information um now why audit for
misinformation in particular right so
currently there is this disproportionate
focus on uh AI bias and fairness and and
tech journalist Karen how captures this
notion very well in her article where
she mentions how often responsible AI
teams in companies are pigeon hold into
targeting AI bias uh now don't get me
wrong so bias and fairness are indeed
important topics that one should pursue
but tackling jti bias uh draws away
attention from fixing much bigger
problems uh of other types of harmful uh
information such as misinformation
extremism conspiratorial content so this
is what is the underlying motivation
behind the set of studies that we did
did um and with that uh let's dive into
this first study the YouTube audit
work here uh a major motivation for this
YouTube study was coming from these
frequent headlines that uh I was
noticing a few years ago how YouTube is
driving people in the internet's darkest
corners and then there were these
opinion pieces uh talking about YouTube
being the great
radicalize um but you was also
responding um with articles saying that
they will be reducing conspiracy theory
recommendations or making it much harder
to find those on the
platform but uh all these questions and
all these reports are really anecdotal
like how empirically how bad is this
right do we really know that um and and
this is what a study to try to do verify
these anecdotal claims that is does
YouTube really surface these problematic
content and in order to do this we
conducted the systematic audits on
YouTube search and recommendation
algorithms and we picked one type of
problematic content conspiracy theories
now what really is an audit right I've
have talked about mentioned audit a
couple of times so far but how do you
audit algorithms uh I'm sure some of you
in the audience might be familiar with
uh with uh the concept of audit for for
those of you who who don't know I'm
going to give you a quick definition
through an example and also say that uh
this is a thriving field of research
lots of work has been done in this uh
space and this was one of the earliest
example of a audits coming from the
social science world and it's also one
of my favorite ones from this 2004 paper
where researchers conducted this very
clever field experiment to investigate
employment dis uh discrimination that is
they audited the labor market for racial
discrimination so what they did was they
responded with fictitious resumés to
help wanted ads in the Boston and
Chicago newspapers to manipulate the
perception of race uh what they did was
they kept everything else in each of
these rumes constant only they changed
the names and the names were either U
very African-American sounding name such
as Lakisha or Jamal or a very white
sounding name such as Emily or Greg and
hence the name of this paper the results
showed that there was significant
discrimination against African-American
names while white names uh receive 50%
more call backs for interviews uh
compared to uh the African-American
names despite everything else being
constant in those resumés so this is a
core idea behind audits that is you
would keep everything else constant and
then you manipulate a single variable to
determine how that change would affect
the algorithm so if you translate this
into the context of YouTube um you would
manipulate a variable to determine
whether the search and recommendation
algorithm returns different results say
when someone's age their uh other
demographic attributes gender their
watch History uh where they are
searching for from the geolocation if
that differs what happens with the
research
results so to answer this we set up this
elaborate audit framework which broadly
looked like this where we had programmed
Bots or in other words we were
conducting these sock puppet audits so
these were Bots or sock puppets which
behave like normal users logging into
YouTube running queries on the search
platform while at the same time a script
at the back end were collecting whatever
search and recommendation results the
platform was uh
returning so we started with selecting
search topics and a goal here was to
make sure that the topics are indeed
high impact that is lots of people are
searching for these topics so they
should be popular uh and they should be
topics which also have the potential to
return false conspiracies uh so we did
some uh more background work referring
to Wikipedia comparing with Google
Trends and we came up with this uh list
of five different topics 911
conspiracies vaccine controversies
moonlanding conspiracies chemtrail and
then Flat Earth and then we audited
three components of YouTube the up next
uh video the top five recommendations
and also YouTube's uh search
results for demographics we checked for
four different different age groups and
two different types of gender male and
female uh and to emulate this we had to
create uh eight different sock puppet uh
combination accounts and then uh for
geolocation uh we uh found this hot and
cold regions that is uh we call these
hot and cold regions because these are
the regions which have the highest or
the lowest interest for that particular
topic and we found these hot and cold
regions comparing with Google's uh
Google Trends interest overtime graph uh
so this is how it looked like for all
the topics so for example example if you
pick the flatter Earth theories Montana
was a hot uh region or a highin uh
showing region while New Jersey is a low
interest or Co region so once we had all
these parameters the demography uh
geolocation and all these parameters we
essentially created bot accounts or sock
puppets and programmed these accounts to
keep firing queries on YouTube for
geolocation these Bots fired queries uh
from IP addresses of these
locations now one very important thing
that uh we had to do for running these
audits is throughout these audit
experiments you would have to control
for noise to ensure that the effect that
you're observing is actually from uh the
algorithm is not because of the noise um
that might have uh int been introduced
while running the experiment so um we
controlled for browser Eyes by selecting
one single version of Firefox browser um
we made sure that the YouTube searches
are happening uh simultaneously to
control for temporal effects and so
on so all of that audit Run results Ed
in about 56,000 more than 56,000 videos
um uh uh uh capturing about 3,000 unique
uh videos and then was the hard part
right the the manual annotations for
this data set and and I can go into
detail of why we went with manual
annotations and how we annotated if
anyone is interested in the Q&A round
but essentially this resulted in uh kind
of three sets of annotations promoting
neutral and debunking and there was a
lot of thought process that went into
these annotation scheme why these uh
three class made sense for this purpose
and so on um and then we performed
statistical comparison test to
essentially find out what what's the
result of these audits so let's look at
some of these uh so what did we find uh
we found that for brand new accounts uh
demography and geolocation do not really
have an effect on the amount of
misinformation on cons or the type of
conspiracy theories that these platforms
are or YouTube is um is is uh returning
this is encouraging this is what we want
the platform to do right so it tells us
that unlike those um uh reports which
were blaming YouTube for returning
conspiracy theories when it's a brand
new account uh turns out the demography
and G location do not really have an
effect but once a account spills a
history uh by watching both demography
and geolocation starts exerting an uh an
effect on the recommendation um for
certain combination of topics stances
and component uh now you might be
thinking okay this is expected right
this is what we what we how we think the
the platform would behave but turns out
there are a little bit more nuan results
when we dig deeper into these the the
actual audit outcomes so for for example
for the 911 topic if the sock puppets
watched YouTube uh videos promoting line
Evan conspiracy you would end up getting
more of these promoting videos in the
recommendations but if the topic is
something different so for surprisingly
for vaccine topic the effect was
completely opposite if you watch
antivaccine videos YouTube ended up
recommending you debunking videos in the
up next and top five
recommendations so uh this uh at least
from these observations it it it tells
us that YouTube in some some way is
handling misinformation in a much more
reactive way it's uh modifying its
search and recommendation algorithms
selectively based on what reactions is
getting from the media and Technology
critics so we know that there there was
a lot of push back for for vaccine
related misinformation and it appears
that they have gone and fixed that but
they have not done that universally for
other um problematic topics we also
found that certain demographics were
prone to conspiracy video
recommendations so for example among
eight of those demographic cases in all
but one case men accounts that is bought
accounts who had gender set at set as
male were recommended more
misinformative
videos and perhaps most surprisingly
what we found that in four of these
cases men accounts who actually ended up
watching neutral videos uh got
significantly higher misinformative
video recommendations now this is really
problematic it implies that the
algorithm was actually recommending
procons conspiracy videos even when uh
the user or in this case sock puppet was
watching neutral videos on the topic
what could this mean for real users uh
this means that recommending promoting
videos to men who are already drawn to
neutral information for that topic but
have not yet developed a pro conspiracy
beliefs but now has a higher chance of
developing that because the platform is
is returning um these uh uh promoting
conspiratorial um
videos so uh wrapping up this work um
the key contribution of of uh this study
was that in some sense this this work
developed a methodology to audit search
engines for misinformation and we were
also able to statistically prove that
YouTube's Behavior varies across
different misinformative topics and our
study also identified um certain
populations that could be potentially
targets of uh certain types of
misinformation uh so this tells us that
audit itself could be a useful way uh
for um studying how algorithms might
have differential impacts on certain
marginalized uh populations yes Qui
question so I get what you're saying
about it being reactive like the
evidence suggests that that that in this
case it's like being special case do you
have a proposal as to how it might not
be reactive like how how how could they
be proactive is there is there something
you would propose that they do instead
yeah so I think one of the things they
could do and I think they are doing it
uh now in hindsight this is an older
study is they're sitting with like teams
of experts uh Health experts and also
kind of looking at these uh you know
health related queries and topics in
advance uh to figure out kind of doing
these red teaming exercises they call it
red teaming I think in the research will
we call it audit so they they're doing
this beforehand to figure out whether
the platform is written returning um uh
you know problematic content and and so
if they do more of that proactively uh
of course there is you know some hope in
in kind of changing um changing things
and you know we should not be catching
these reactively after the fact now that
if that that assumes that the sort of
points of view are stable right so like
we often have these scenarios where like
you know culture changes or something
goes viral like the Tide Pods or
whatever where I don't think a red team
would have come up with oh yeah we're
gonna start eating bleach or whatever
right um is there an approach there that
you would Advocate like if you were in
charge of one of these teams over yeah I
think one of the things that um May I
think some researchers at Stanford uh
maybe it was one of your student who did
uh the this work with crowd audits right
like where where where the crowd itself
is reporting like because it's not
really possible for the red team to find
all possible scenarios under which uh uh
under which this uh these these sorts of
problem happen and I think that's where
if you have these multiple eyes uh from
different domains and different cultures
to report those problems and then it um
kind of the company actually responds to
it the problem is if the company's not
responding or or the people who are
building these algorithm if they're not
responding to it and so hopefully there
should be a mechanism to do that um kind
of closing that lube uh all the way from
reporting to actually taking
action so moving on to Amazon um I think
uh what one of the things that led us to
looking at Amazon is despite being these
leading e retailer platform how less of
a focus uh research Focus um has been
paid to this platform and and and I
think uh what was alarming is um uh
there were several media reports at the
time coming out suggesting that Amazon's
algorithm were putting health and
vaccine misinformation at the top of
your reading list but uh there there was
very little research to fall back uh to
either verify or even you know kind of
uh disprove these uh these reports so if
you search on Amazon unlike YouTube
which is at least tried to control for
vaccine misinformation uh searching on
Amazon for vaccine even this morning
when I when I searched I could actually
find some of these these books um you
would end up getting several anti
vaccination products mostly in the form
of uh books and and the recommendation
algorithm for Amazon are even much more
sophisticated than YouTube uh so you
have your product page recommendation
which has all these many different
layers customers who bought items
sponsored products related to these
items you have your homepage
recommendations again many different
layers underneath uh pre-purchase uh
page recommendations uh which is shown
to you after you add a product to the
cart that is after the user shows an
intention to buy that
product um so again we we this was the
same question uh as before how bad is
the scenario uh so we essentially wanted
to conduct the systematic audits on
Amazon search and recommendation
algorithm and we here we picked only one
type of problematic content vaccine
misinformation um and we conducted two
sets of audits unpersonalized one and
then the personalized audits the
personalized audits goal was to assess
whether users uh account History built
progressively by a user performing
certain actions such as clicking on a
product adding the product to the cart
showing their intention to buy does any
of those actions how does that change
what recommendation is being returned
and here the user built these account
history progressively uh by performing a
particular action for uh seven
consecutive days uh so these were again
when I say users these were sock puppets
searching searching plus clicking
searching plus clicking plus adding the
product to the card so all these were
different actions that were performed um
and then we also controlled for noise
very similar setup as before uh just
with the caveat that this whole audit
experiment setup was a big software
engineering feat uh considering you know
the amount of different uh combinations
of recommendations possible on Amazon um
so what did we find so I'm going to
highlight a couple of results here first
a single case study result uh so let's
say user start searching for vaccine and
they click on an antivaccine book uh so
as of this morning this this book was
actually there on their platform in the
first page first search result page um
and so if if the user clicks on this
that algorithm next serves the user
three other antivaccine books in the
product recommendation page and then
once the user um adds a product or book
to the card that it shows their
intention to buy both the pre- purchase
as well as a homepage recommendation
also rapidly changes with many more
antivaccine book recommendations so this
just tells you that once a user starts
engaging with one misinformative product
on this e-commerce platform they will be
presented with more of those similar
stuff at every point of their Amazon
navigation
route so this was not just a one-off
case study we found found that more than
10% of Amazon products uh during the
time period of our study for Search
terms like vaccine autism immunization
uh resulted in misinformative uh book
contain anti containing antiv
vaccination uh content and so our audit
experiment just to give you the scale of
this uh experiment this was ran for a
little bit over 3 weeks resulted in
36,000 search results several uh 16,000
recommendations and then uh worked over
several search filters like featured
sponsored different recommendation types
user actions and so all of that resulted
in that number of more than 10% so if
you just zoom out and look at what these
uh thousands of recommendations uh look
like uh this is the entire
recommendation graph for one type of
recommendation what other items
customers buy after viewing this
item uh so here each node in the graph
represents a product an Amazon product
and an edge from a node a to a node B
indicates that b was recommended in the
product page of
node size here is proportional to the
number of times the product was
recommended and the color corresponds to
whether if it's a red if it denotes a
product annotators as misinformative
green neutral and then blue uh debunking
and I think um being you know all of you
have CS degree so or are almost about to
get a CS degree so you would probably
able to decipher what's going on in this
graph um there are these large red sides
no attached to other red nodes which are
almost completely separated
there are like two separate components
right so uh this just shows how strong
of a filter bubble effect there is for
this particular recommendation people
who are recommended misinformative
products they keep getting recommended
those products super hard for them to
break out from that Red Zone to get to
the blue or the green zone s just a
clarification I think you mentioned this
but how did you code something as
misinformative or not like obviously
there's lots of Shades of Gray here yes
so uh we the there was initial say is we
went through an extensive annotation
scheme theme of uh uh the a set of U and
then we also built a classifier to do
that but the entire there were like lot
more details in the paper as to how we
uh coded it but I think I think it took
us almost a month to even uh come up
with the whole annotation scheme and
then you know five or six of experts
including me we kind of coded uh coted
it but yes so we looked at a few markers
like the name of the book The text uh
read the you know the Google preview of
the text of the BR book some of the
comments and then also the reviews uh
that are present on the Amazon uh
website uh so it's a lot more
qualitative process and then all the
markers that we took we also uh put it
into the classifier to uh get the final
annotations so this would have been more
like the overall position of the book
not like oh was there a fact somewhere
in there that yeah yeah so yes we cannot
really go and look at okay this there is
this one single line in the text in the
book which is misinformative uh no but
yes so there there you could say there's
a little bit of noise in
there and so this was another one just
to say that you know this was not
happening for one recommendation uh
customers who viewed this item also
viewed very similar graph as before um
very similar Trend and so the key
takeaway here was our goal was to bring
the focus uh to e-commerce platforms and
show how their algorithms could be
pushing um antivaccine content to users
and we empirically established how
certain real world user actions on the
platform form uh could drive users to
these problematic Eco Chambers I think
one of the uh uh implications at least
for from this work is that
recommendation algorithms uh should not
be blindly applied to all topics equally
if it's a health topic uh perhaps
companies need to pay little bit more
attention um and to ensure that there is
higher quality content coming out of um
in their uh for in their
platform so this work of ours um uh
intentionally or unintentionally was
kind of right L timed during the covid
pandemic and so this was widely covered
by several news channels and in fact
congressman Adam Schiff and Elizabeth
Warren actually cited This research of
Arts uh in their letter to Amazon to
control vaccine misinformation so we
were really happy that okay so now
Amazon is going to take few steps to do
this but turns out we were really wrong
uh so this is how Amazon is doing today
still today as of earlier this morning
uh you would still find several books
containing vaccine misinformation uh
this also just tells like how you know
even though you did go into all these
length doing these academic research is
it actually informing policy is it
actually making any real world impact
and we can go into a long discussion
about that that but uh in the interest
of time let me talk a little bit more uh
on um uh one other type of study that we
did uh looking at another type of audit
method so so far the studies that I
presented employed one type of audit
method soft puppet audits while these
audits provide the Great control over
your experimental design um you can
pinpoint exactly which variable might be
affecting the output of the algorithm
but one criticism of these audits is
that the bot's behavior are usually
built in a very conservative way right
so the bot in this YouTube case was
essentially going and watching all pro
conspiracy videos or all debunking
videos real users do not really act
exactly that that way right so these are
these very extreme bot behaviors or user
behaviors um so as an alternative we
conducted crowdsourced audits where we
audited the algorithmic outputs from
Real World users to study and identify
problematic behavior in users
naturalistic setting so we conducted
this audit for uh 9-day duration on
YouTube and our goal was to assess um to
the extent in which YouTube was
regulating uh us-based election
misinformation on their
platform and so soon after the
presidential election in 2020 YouTube
came under Fire for uh surfacing uh
election related misinformation in their
search and recommendation s and they
quickly responded to those criticisms by
introducing these content moderation
policies to remove videos that spread
election related falsehoods and claimed
that misinformative videos would not be
surfaced on their platform but then
again during the midterm 2020 uh
elections there were reports saying that
YouTube has still has misinformation
blind spots right so um they have not
been very effective so this study of
ours uh was goal was to determine how
effective YouTube was in successfully
implementing its content moderation
policy and so we did this through this
post Haw crowdsourced audit why it's
post talk because it's conducted after
the fact the event has happened
elections of 2020 and we were conducting
the St study in 2022 and it's crowd sour
started since we investigate you's
algorithm collecting data for from Real
World
users um and uh I'm sure many of you who
have run these sorts of uh recruitment
studies uh you would realize how
difficult and how hard it is to do that
essentially we were asking users to um
lend their YouTube history uh so that we
can do this sort of uh audit run um and
so our crowdsourced investigation um I
think we started with like recruiting
600 to 500 users and we ended up U
slightly lower than 100 users so 99 uh
particularly so all these 99 users first
filled out a pre- survey and about their
beliefs on personalization on YouTube
how they trust you search and
recommendation algorithm and then they
installed this browser extension uh
which allowed us to collect users
personalized data we also had all these
ethical considerations um which I can go
on um into more detail if anyone is
interested but what this extension was
doing it was collecting search results
of search queries uh related to the 2020
US presidential election as well as
voter fraud claims surrounding the 2020
elections so two kinds of uh collection
was happening one was with respect to
search results um in the standard and
incognito window and by comparing these
search results in both these windows our
goal was to tell the extent in which
YouTube was personalizing search results
and then we were also collecting
recommendation results and the way we
were doing this we were collecting these
up next recommendation Trails after user
has watched a list of uh pre-selected
videos with different stances on
Election
misinformation and the extension would
start by first first watching a
pre-selected seed video and then
collecting up next uh videos up to five
different
levels um so when we asked our
participants in this pre- study survey
how much do you think YouTube
personalizes your search results about
34% of them believe that YouTube
personalizes their search results to a
really great extent but this uh through
our audit we found that YouTube actually
that their YouTube stop search results
have little to no personalization so
this also tells you how users believe uh
in algorithms like the way they behave
uh is is different from actually the way
uh the the platform might be
behaving uh but when we asked how much
you do personalizes their up next
recommendation that perception actually
aligned with how actually the audit
result showed like 51% of participants
believe that YouTube personalizes UPN
recommendation to a great extent which
is in line with what are audit results
found we also calculate the amount of
misinformation present in search results
uh and we Quantified this with this
misinformation bias score and this is
the only equation you're going to see
throughout this talk um so this
misinformation bias score varies from
minus one to1 what the score does is it
captures amount of uh misinformation
election related misinformation while
taking into account the ranking of the
search results so a positive score
indicates that search results contain
videos that support election
misinformation while negative um it
contain videos that oppose election
misinformation now if you look at the
entire distribution of scores for our
collector results we found that the
misinformation score if you look at the
uh x-axis it's mostly negative which
indicates that YouTube presents more
debunking or opposing videos in the
search results a couple of other key
things also jumps off right so you could
see um there are uh this distribution is
by model uh so essentially there are two
different clusters and each of these
clusters corresponds to two types of
search queries um I mean we didn't uh
cluster it ahead of time right this this
uh emerged from our data so the first
cluster corresponds to water fraud um uh
basically anything related to fraud in
conjunction with keywords related to
election while cluster two is more
generic election related searches
presidential election mailin ballots and
so on um what what's uh interesting here
is that the cluster one uh has these
missions information bias score which
are more negative which indicates that
if if the user goes and search for fraud
related topics they are actually going
to be given more opposite election
related misinformation video right so
it's making YouTube is making it really
difficult for users to search for
election fraud video uh which in some
sense tells that YouTubes pay more
attention to queries about election
fraud and ensures that when users are
searching for them they are uh in fact
being exposed to opposing misinformation
videos so key takeaway here is um in
some way YouTube is in fact successful
in enacting election misinformation
policy so things that we wanted to test
uh turns out uh it's actually um you
know aligning with how they wanted to
enforce these policies but it is indeed
paying special attentions to certain
queries about water fraud but there
still exists certain misinformation in
the UPN next uh Trails we found that uh
with some of those positive scores that
you found um and then finally as a
byproduct of this uh audit uh we also
found that there was some mismatch in
participants beliefs and the algorithmic
reality um that that happens right uh
which indicates the lack some lack of
awareness of algorithmic uh how
algorithms behave and I think um there
has been uh other researchers who have
been working in this space um looking at
algorithmic folk theories um and and how
people's perception differ from the way
uh these these uh platforms
work now uh uh wrapping up so these
three these all are you know the core
studies that I wanted to present but
obviously coming back to how I started
the talk where do we go from here right
how do we uh do meaningful algorithmic
governance in the first place that is
how do we set the path towards
algorithmic governance uh in a
meaningful way and what are the
challenges in doing
that so here are a few ideas and
obviously this is not uh expans uh you
know there might be more that could be
added but these are the some of the
possibilities for doing algorithmic
governance so I've listed three of these
the first is algorithmic uh uh Audits
and so governance WIA Audits and there
could be many layers to this right so
one of the lay is uh conducting external
Audits and I presented some of these
external audits uh studies uh through
the three um uh research work that we
have done in the past um and also these
audits could identify different types of
risks so misinformation is one risk but
you could also do the same for bias
discrimination accountability
accessibility accessibility fairness and
so on and and there are many um uh
researchers who have worked in the space
I've listed some of these citations here
but obviously our question is uh so we
as academic Community third party
researchers we are doing all this audits
is it really making any difference right
and and classic example is the failure
of our Amazon study to make much of a
difference right so we still really
don't have a system in place where the
algorithms or companies running them are
truly accountable to an independent
third party so this reminds me how us
space Consumer Reports operate right so
there are these independent thirdparty
organizations that go into great length
for testing products that you use every
day your cars your washing machine and
so on uh but so my argument is that why
can't we do the same for algorithm in
fact I would argue that we need that
more for algorithms because we are using
them much more frequently than say your
uh washing
machine the other shortcoming with
external audit is that there are a form
of reactive governance this was a
question that Michael was asking even
earlier like they operate after the
algorithm have been deployed so after
the harm has been done plus the external
Auditors do not really have access to
the models to the training data which
are obviously protected as straight
secrets so as an alternative another
layer to uh governance via audits is you
could do internal audits as proactive
governance and so uh at the time uh
researchers from Google who are no
longer at Google at the um uh right now
but they released this paper um making a
case for internal audits where audit
would be part of a core part of product
development at every step of the way
uh you could also do The Best of Both
Worlds right you could do something
called Cooperative audits which is a
fairly newer concept where uh while
external audits answers what problems
the platform has uh and internal audit
says why that's happening you could have
a combination of both and you could do
Cooperative audits as shared governance
which allows external algorithm Auditors
to audit the system of willing private
companies so I've done a little bit of
this uh with um uh U Spotify where uh
working with their Engineers uh in the
within the company uh figuring out how
gender representations might be biased
or not for their taste on boarding and
listen action on
podcasts and then finally you also need
to do these audits multiple times right
longitudinally that is we need to
conduct these continuous audits
monitoring platforms multiple times
instead of that single snapshot audit
many of my studies that I presented
today are all single snapshot and we do
need that kind of longitudinal effort
so here is where I want to highlight uh
one of the uh quotes from the bra's
earlier internal audit paper where they
uh mention the audit process is
necessarily boring it is slow it is
meticulous and methodological methodical
which is which stands in STK contrast to
the uh what I had started my earlier
slides with move fast and break things
done is better than perfect so very much
in contrast with the rushed culture of
Technology development and this is where
I want to take a little bit of tangent
then mentioned about audit possibilities
one of the fastest growing uh developing
AI Technologies a large language models
and what would auditing even look like
for large language models what's the
blueprint for llm a auditing and then
also what are the key challenges right
uh so one of the key challenges that it
is difficult to assess the risks that AI
systems and large language models in
particular pose independent of the
context in which they are deployed right
so we do need application specific uh
audits for large language models the
Second Challenge is that and I don't
know how to solve this or rather even
the first one is that the capabilities
and the training processes of these
foundational models have really outpaced
the development of the tools and and te
techniques uh and the procedures for
auditing right uh so it's really hard to
keep up uh the pace and so doing ethical
legal and technically robust audits
makes it super challenging for such a
rapidly developing um technology and so
that it must be complemented probably
with with much more newer forms of
supervision and control so here is one
possible framework one possible
blueprint for auditing large language
models which is kind of three layers so
the first one is a model audit um so as
a name suggests it focuses on assessing
the technical properties of the pre-tin
language models so this is very similar
flavor to the internal audit uh that I
mentioned earlier so that's sort of
proactive governance before you deploy
the model but then there is the
application audit which focuses on the
the assessing the applications built on
top of the llms uh so which is these
flavors of post talk audit right um and
and it should be done longitudinally
multiple times over a long period of
time so as to capture any sort of new
properties that might be emerging and
then finally I think this is the new
form of audit that we haven't uh talked
about a lot at least the research
Community these are these governance
audits that is assessing the processes
whereby these language models are
designed and where they are disseminated
so very much process oriented
right um my next proposition is about
value centered audits that is uh there
is this active conversation around um
social values emphasizing while
designing algorithms and I think we also
need to turn that attention and thinking
into how we can value and respect humans
involved in the audit process so these
humans could be in the form of users who
use the system or even Auditors who are
investigating uh the the sites um and so
for Auditors if we bring back the
conversation for a second back to
misinformation one of one instance where
Auditors did not really feel perceive
fair treatment um was this scenario
where you know fact Checkers are one of
the key Auditors of misinformation on
online platforms like Facebook Twitter
so the fact checking organizations
Snopes a couple of years ago actually
backed out of their partnership with
Facebook because they didn't feel the
their values were being
respected I think to delve into this
question of fair treatment of Auditors
we need more effort and so one way in
which my group uh has has started a few
initiatives uh we have launched a
research Endeavor with the factchecking
organization based in Kenya called
pesach and this has also expanded to 16
other factchecking organization across
four different continents and we
released our first report uh called the
human and technological infrastructures
of uh factchecking um and so uh one big
uh motivation for this work was also
this question of are we really taking
into account diverse voices when we are
talking about governance and governing
Technologies and are we really doing
culturally responsible
AI finally how do we ensure actionable
audits that is audits that result in
real change so one of the most
successful examples of an actionable
audit uh is uh Joy bami's gender shade
study um so what she did was she audited
um facial recognition algorithms and
within 7 months of the release of these
original audit all the three companies
who had their facial recognition apps uh
released new API versions that reduced
uh accuracy disparities uh in with
gender male and female as well as race
darker and lighter skinned uh subgroups
so in other words that gender shade
study is a classic example of commercial
actual impact and so they laid out their
approach in this actionable auditing
paper of theirs highly recommend you all
to go and refer to it but turns out
actionable auditing is often
tremendously difficult to achieve and
here is where I want to revisit that
earlier slide for our Amazon study
to highlight how much we had failed in
doing the actionable auditing right so
despite widespread media coverage
despite a letter to from congressional
um congressman Adam Schiff Amazon did
not really act much all they did was add
that Banner of uh covid-19 uh
information directing to cdc's web page
so hopefully uh this kind of summarizes
the challenges as well as the
opportunities and setting the path for
algorithmic governance and hoping uh
with the new regulations coming in in in
place uh maybe if I were to give this
talk uh next year I would have a little
bit more hopeful slide than how I'm
ending this uh talk um uh so so that's
it so this is all I talked about uh
today uh most of this work uh was done
with my phds then PhD student Pina Juna
who is now a faculty at Seattle
University uh and then I uh my group I
would also stick in three other threads
of work which I obviously don't have
time to talk about uh but these are like
uh a couple of other other amazing
students so uh shuti for she did a bunch
of work on computational social science
I was earlier meeting a a student who is
doing this sort of work so um things
like big data analysis of online
interactions um studying trajectories of
participation of users in extreme
communities conspiratorial communities
we have also done a a little bit of
design intervention and social system
design work um with another student who
is also a faculty now uh this is of an
xci flavor where essentially questions
like how do you design a system to nudge
users towards meaningful credibility
assessment how do you design a system uh
to uh uh to allow users to break out of
their filter bubble uh something called
other tube that we built on YouTube and
then finally uh the the last and uh the
least fleshed out thread is uh some of
the work that is currently ongoing with
two of my students we're looking at
challenges or and opportunities of
generative AI in factchecking work
and then what are some cultural
misalignment that might happen with
language models uh especially uh you
know with with roots in the global South
we are looking at cultural implications
of these language models in in countries
like India and other countries in in
Southeast Asia uh so with that I would
like to end and happy to take questions
thank you
[Applause]
all all right we've got time for some
questions
yeah I was wondering in your auditing of
YouTube algorithms that you guys looked
at well I guess it was in 2020 so I
wasn't sure if YouTube shorts had been
implemented since then because YouTube
shorts are somewhat of a newer aspect
but I wonder if the algorithms that
underly um the I guess traditional
YouTube recommendation system underly
the same sort of like YouTube shorts
recommendation because I guess the
length of content and sort of the amount
of stimulus that would be needed to get
the person to keep on scrolling would be
different and therefore possibly seeing
that if there are sort of similar
patterns between the two whether or not
the
um the the density I guess of sort of
misinformation sort of increases because
of the fact that content is more short
form yeah so for the first study we that
time shots were not there but then for
the third one that I presented with the
election misinformation we did capture
YouTube shots uh and that tells me that
we should probably do another analysis
comparing the length of the videos and
the you know whether it's a short video
versus a long form we did not do that
but that's an excellent point
yeah another question on the to study is
a b first one did you look at all at
like the probability that you would get
recommended legitimately false
conspiracy videos like on the moonland
from
videos about conspiracies that are a
little bit more true like missing
persons cases that the police just don't
investigate and like the likelihood that
you'll get recommended actually false
content yeah we did not because I think
one of the shortcomings of um running
audits is the whole setup itself so we
have to start somewhere right so the our
our starting point were a set of seed
queries right so with the way you are
framing it it you know we could the
hypothesis could be does a missing
person's case lead you to more
conspiratory videos and in that scenario
I think we can use our audit framework
to have those ass seed queries um and
see what
happens
there on your kind of concluding point
about actionable audits I'm just curious
do do you think it's something to do
with like the conducting of the audit
itself or just the context and how it
aligns with like the company incentives
because it it feels like the gender
Shades case it was like a very easily
framed as like poor performance and so
they were trying to cover themselves
whereas Amazon is somewhat incentivized
to keep people buying things even if
those things are harmful so like I I
guess I'm wondering like do you think
audits need to be conducted differently
or there just needs to be more external
pressure like from the government or the
public to incentivize the companies when
they aren't like internally incentivized
think it's a latter I I think I think uh
Joy went on to great extent to after the
study was published to kind of give
talks and publicize and do that kind of
Outreach which I did not do with this
work I think that matters a lot right
she's the one who went to a
congressional testimony and testified
against these companies um and when you
do uh uh that that kind of impact it
would definitely translate or there's a
higher chance to be for your work to be
translated to uh actual action
actionable um outcome I don't think
those are actually steps listed in the
actionable auditing paper um and in some
sense I feel like maybe the academic
Community need to think about how to
incentivize those additional work we
don't have those incentives in place and
partly I think we should look Inward and
and blame ourselves that we don't have
those incentives in
place to this a but I just wanted to
hear your thoughts more um when being
either in know Proactive or reactive um
do you think we should a distinction
between um conspiracy theories or
misinformation that has potential for
great harm versus those that maybe don't
right to justify interventions that
override individual autonomy or control
the information space like who is the
moon landing
cons can you say that last partou the
moon landing conspiracy presumably isn't
hurting anyone right it should yeah
should we take it down yeah that's a
really good point and I think uh for
companies like Google I know they have
this your money or your life um they
have a weird ACM ym yl or something um
uh set of search guidelines if it's uh
if if if those uh search results are or
the pages that show up if it's affecting
monetarily financially health or your
life then they're going to be more
proactive and act on it so you're right
like moon landing is probably not uh to
that extent versus if it's vaccine
information that has direct life
consequences right but obviously then
there are these all these other
questions that when it's very well known
that if you are drawn to one conspiracy
the you're you're likely to get other
conspiracy theories right so then what
what happens should should those be Dre
prior at least to the extent that they
maybe should be prior prioritized in the
recommendations if not completely
removed from the
platform yeah oh this is sort of uh
another sort of idea that I had um sort
of looking at the idea of like what I
think is sort of interesting about like
social media apps like YouTube is the
whole aspect of the the immediate being
able to communicate with others like via
the comment section of a YouTube channel
and I was wondering if there was a way
to possibly like I'm not sure how
present this is or if this is even like
a thing that is that is even like
something that is a able to be like
looked into but is there a possibility
that the algorithm isn't
May almost be promoting you content not
necessarily by what it's
physically um providing like showing up
them recommended but showing other users
who would most likely put other links to
more I guess like Extreme videos in the
comments being like Oh if you thought
this was interesting like look at this
and so that's not explicitly YouTube's
algorithm showing you a video it's
showing that same video to someone else
who has the ability to share a link to
another YouTube you video that would be
almost like pushing someone down like a
pipeline of conspiracy theories so more
like how the social
recommendations like you sort of adding
this collaborative social recommendation
component to YouTube and seeing how that
pushes like if if YouTube like you could
have the same effect like in theory
maybe the YouTube recommendation system
could not explicitly push someone by
recommending like more intense
conspiracy theories but if YouTube is
recommending someone who's already like
a very like entrenched conspiracy
theorist and maybe someone who's on the
edge if YouTube recommends them both the
same like on like starting out
conspiracy theory video then you can
have the person who's like very
entrenching conspiracy theories
commenting and suggesting things
themselves that and it's not that
YouTube is explicitly recommending the
original person but the person who isn't
like uh Ed conspiracy theory it's that
they put them essentially on on the same
PL or they put them in the same
environment in which they could
communicate yeah
so actually my group of some of shui's
work we have done this in the in the
context of Reddit where what you are
describing those very entrenched
conspiracy users we term this as veteran
users and so they are one of the big
drivers of bringing other people like
what we call joiners into the community
of conspiracy group so I I hope YouTube
never does that what you're suggesting
but but that's a classic marker of how
these social dynamics can actually bring
people into these conspiratorial
worldviews and you know empirically um
we have seen that and there is also
social science theory proving that that
definitely
happens yeah one challenge that I feel
like our field faces with audits is I
guess what I would describe as the sense
I get of frustration from Folks at these
companies who feel like the audience
audits
aren't well executed or are way out of
date as soon as they're published and
you you made this point that you know we
have to be meth you know very methodical
and often slow in doing this then you
throw in the uh peer review pipeline
that can slow things down further yeah
and by the time the thing comes out I
remember seeing like you know an applied
research someone a researcher in a
company who in principle would be more
open to this kind of stuff being like
our them doesn't even work like that
anymore and so I'm wondering like so
obviously you listed a bunch of possible
you know Cooperative audits longitudinal
internal and so on I'm curious are there
is there anything we can do to address
that like let's let's assume that you
know we can't change the incentives of
the companies we can't you know change
how quickly we do the audits is it are
we always going
to be vulnerable to this like oh yeah
that was yesterday's algorithm kind of
critique yeah yeah I that's that's a
really good point in fact you know we I
was at a workshop with other folks like
Christo Wilson and few others who are in
this have done audits for a very long
time with people from Facebook and
YouTube and I think the the the com we
came up with this exact same question
and I think the common thing that
emerged was that I don't think academics
should be the or academic institutions
should be the places to uh do these
sorts of long-term audits it's fine to
kind of develop the methods and um and
you know kind of say okay this one
should pay attention for example to
Amazon or you know this is the method to
do it but then you need like separate
third- party companies to continuously
do these audits right so sort of like
Consumer Reports how does what's the
equivalent of that for Audits and I
think at cscw the closing keynote uh
room room was mentioning that kind of
red teaming I think their company or
whichever NGO she's working with they
are doing something like that I think so
academics with that PE review process I
don't think we should be responsible for
doing those sorts of continuous audits
because we are always going to play
catch up with with uh
companies
yeah oh one last yeah at the end do you
have thoughts on like Twitter has
implemented like Community notes where
people can just like anyone can just WR
under a post like that's not true or
this is misleading or this person never
said that like just like user based
immediate type auditing if you will like
do you have thoughts on that versus like
companies long-term auditing or like if
you think that's a good idea yeah it's a
really good point we haven't looked at
Community notes but I know uh you know
some researchers have um kind of looked
and researched it I don't have really
any very smart thoughts as to other than
the usual advice that it's a good thing
that one should do it but with the
caveat that um if the community is uh
doesn't reflect uh the right view or or
I I wouldn't use the word right but you
know the um a credible view of what
happens then uh right that that's
problematic
so I think that's time so let's thank
our speaker thank you thanks
everyone